in september of 2019 a six-year-old
student named kaya
was sitting in her school's office okay
she's gonna have to come with us now
that's a police officer this video comes
from his body camera
at first it seems like kaya doesn't know
what's happening
[Music]
earlier that day kaya had a tantrum
three school employees said that she had
kicked them
the school called the police who
arrested kaya
on charges of misdemeanor battery
the police dropped the charges after
kaya's grandmother sent this video to
the orlando sentinel
kaia's case isn't an isolated incident
[Music]
a five-year-old girl being handcuffed by
police in florida
for a year he could not sleep alone he
put handcuffs on me
tossed to the ground by a school
resource officer
what you're seeing are the effects of a
larger problem in american schools
the u.s doesn't treat all students
equally
but if we wanted to we could do
something about that
the next president could decide if that
happens
[Music]
in 2016 researchers at yale showed
teachers
this video clip of four preschool
students
their instructions look for misbehavior
and click when you see it the study was
kind of deceptive
none of the kids in the video actually
misbehaved
the researchers were using eye tracking
software
what they actually wanted to study was
who the teachers
were watching both black and white
teachers
spent significantly more time watching
the black boy
in the video this study showed that even
preschool teachers
can treat kids differently based on
their race without even realizing it
look elsewhere in the u.s school system
and you'll see this show up in other
ways
like at this middle school in bryan
texas
they gave students tickets for offenses
like disrupting class
or using profanity black students were
four times more likely than white
students
to receive those tickets nationwide
black boys miss way more school due to
suspensions
than any other group and this can start
a kind of chain reaction
missing weeks of school due to
suspensions makes students much more
likely to drop
out without a diploma you're much less
likely to earn a living wage
and much more likely to be incarcerated
all this missing school is helping to
drive the highest poverty and
incarceration rates in the developed
world
so it's worth asking how'd we get here
in 1964 president lyndon johnson created
a new federal office
accountable to the president the office
for civil rights
its first task was to desegregate public
schools in the south
but soon they started noticing that some
schools were segregating their students
without actually
calling it segregation a lot of the
black students would be labeled
disabled and removed from the mainstream
classroom
so they wound up segregated daniel
lowson studies school discipline
for years he's been sounding the alarm
about how much school black students are
missing
due to suspensions the data he uses in
his reports
comes from the office for civil rights
in the 1970s
they started requiring schools to report
how many students they classified as
disabled
plus suspensions and expulsions all
broken down by race
and gender over the next few decades
those numbers went up
as more punitive ideas about discipline
took hold in american schools
well in some schools gangs and drugs
have taken over our streets and
undermined our schools the idea that if
you don't
you know throw the book at kids when
they're young for every little thing
that they're going to turn into
criminals
it's never any research to show that it
actually worked you never see that
in schools serving mostly white kids
but in 2011 a new report out of texas
started to cast doubt on that approach
the study looked at discipline records
for almost a million students
attract the same kids from seventh grade
all the way through high school
the results were stunning nearly 60
percent of students had been suspended
or expelled
at least once the study also showed that
black students facing school discipline
for the first time
tended to get harsher punishments than
white students
and the more disciplinary violations a
student received
the more likely they were to drop out
clearly texas had a big problem the
question now
was if the problem was bigger than texas
to figure that out the obama
administration turned to the data set
that the office for civil rights had
built
that's how they learned this was a
nationwide problem african american
students are over three times
more likely than their white peers to be
suspended or expelled
often for very similar offenses they
also discovered that the vast majority
of suspensions
were for behaviors like talking back
using profanity or violating the dress
code
non-violent student behaviors many of
which once meant a phone call home
the administration started investigating
school districts where the numbers were
the most damning
one of those districts was bryan texas
home of the discipline tickets in 2013
a woman named marjorie holman filed a
complaint
after her 12 year old son was suspended
for defending himself from a bully
and had to appear in adult criminal
court
the office of civil rights opened an
investigation in brian
along with hundreds of other school
districts if you can't justify what
you're doing and it's having a harmful
impact on one group more than others you
have to
replace it with something else but we
don't
actually know if those changes made a
difference
because the most recent data on the
office of civil rights website
is from the 2015-2016 school year
the year after that things started to
change
the 51-50 vote to confirm betsy devos
the vice president votes
in the affirmative and the nomination is
confirmed in 2017
the office of president trump's new
education secretary
betsy devos sent a memo to the staff at
the office of civil rights
this one super jargony line in the memo
signaled a huge
shift ocr will only apply
a systemic or class action approach
where the individual complaint
allegations themselves raise systemic or
class-wide issues
translation no more looking for patterns
in the data
if the office got a complaint like
marjorie holman's they would look for
one
thing written or verbal proof that an
individual
teacher or administrator had punished
marjorie's son
more harshly because he was black we're
not going to
question that unless there's the
smoking gun of intentional racism
that's what happened in bryan texas when
betsy devos took office
the investigation into bryan's schools
was close to wrapping up
the final report concluded that black
students were subject to disparate
treatment when compared to white
students engaged in the same or similar
conduct
they had dozens of recommendations for
the district revise their discipline
code hire mentors and social workers
extra training for teachers devos's team
scrapped the report and closed the
investigation with no finding of
wrongdoing
and no suggestions for improvement
if you look closely at this clip you can
see joe biden
standing right behind president clinton
as he signs the 1994 crime bill
that bill ushered in new tough on crime
policies
that devastated black communities as a
senator
biden played a key role in getting the
bill passed
we have predators on our streets they
are beyond the pale
many of those people and since then he's
had to confront that history
i haven't always been right the
systematic racism that
most of us whites don't like to
acknowledge even exist it's been built
into every aspect of our system
this policy plan comes from the biden
campaign
in the section titled school discipline
it says that biden would reinstate
obama's discipline guidelines
and would push for every state to submit
a plan
for reducing the use of policies and
practices that push kids out of school
some people believe that all racism is
explicit
a nasty slur a whites only sign a
burning cross
it's unmistakable and it's on purpose
but there's another way of understanding
racism
that laws and policies can have racist
outcomes
even if they don't mention race at all
that you don't always need a smoking gun
to do a whole lot of damage
thanks for watching this episode of our
2020 election series
for this series we asked you what you
wish the candidates would talk about
more
we got more than 12 000 responses
and we made this video because a lot of
you mentioned
education racial justice and mass
incarceration
holly writes that she wants the
candidates to talk about racial
inequality in
education sylvan wants to know how can
the candidates address systemic
discrimination in our country
and agnes wants the candidates to answer
the question how will you address
mass incarceration and school to prison
pipelines that specifically target
communities of color
it's not too late for you to tell us
what you think the candidates should be
talking about
tell us at vox.com election videos
also i want to send a special shout out
to propublica and thank
them for sharing their reporting on the
office of civil rights with us for this
video
they have done some incredible
investigative work on how things have
changed there under betsy devos
so check it out at propublica.org
[Music]